the second important implication is like
I picked up these examples because they
were easy and you could just tell me
what the inverses are but they're not
always so simple for instance don't
write this yet if I said he's a function
I'm just gonna go ahead yes you probably
don't know what the inverse of this
function is off the top of your head if
you did I'd be somewhat intimidated okay
how do we go about finding the inverse
of this function am i calling f in fact
if I know what the original function is
how I find inverse and again the idea is
to swamp okay so if I take this the
implication is to find the inverse the
actual mechanism we use is to swap the
input which is always going to the X
with the output and that will be either
Y or f of X okay
let's let me go this one things have a
go at this one actually I take it back
one minute
you'll see why this is just making it
easier to write now if this is the
original function by the way please be
careful because what I'm about to do is
to find a whole new function right so I
want to have one line which is the
original and another y another Y which
is the inverse okay so I'm gonna make a
big flashing sign that says that's the
original one and now I'm gonna have a
look at the inverse okay I'm just gonna
go ahead and I'm gonna do the switch
okay let's have a go at this if I can X
over here and I'm going to replace every
X I had of there with an why
I could pack up and go home I've done it
I have actually successfully spot but of
course this is not a very useful form
and I know almost nothing about what
this actual function is going to look
like just on that basis what shall I do
here to tidy this because I should
change the subject
right we are used to having this guy is
the output making that subject so let's
do it over here it looks like it's a
tangled mess but it's not that bad right
let's multiply through that seems this
yeah if I want to make why this subject
what am I gonna have to do next yeah I'm
gonna need to collect like terms yeah so
I need all the Y's over here and
everything else on the other side so if
I say X Y take away why that looks like
X plus what are you happy with that the
reason for collecting like terms was so
I can walk before I make it the subject
they need to factorize out don't I
factory guys factorize the out y will
let me hint of mine through okay so if I
say X okay that look okay have I done
anything algebraically wrong so look
okay no it's this full lines of wedding
or three lines really does it look okay
have I made an error so I'm gonna
complete it now now you successfully
found the inverse what does this mean
so come back come back to what we said
live the beginning which is that
geometrically the way to get to a
function and it's inverse the
relationship is their affliction right
okay so what does this look like that's
not a rhetorical question what does this
look like come on tell me something you
know about this graph a suitor at an
original right x equals one and y equals
how do I know it's y equals one because
he's right while since you've done that
I know it's zero or infinity it's gotta
be one of those guys yes and then good
so these become trivial which means that
as you take the limit these guys are
just approaching each other so the ratio
between two those in the same okay so
there that's fine
so now what now what I do with those
I'm trying to okay so it looks like I'll
by the way where are our intercepts I
have some intercepted if x equals
exchange y equals zero that X is equal
to negative one and give X equal zero
why is he also equal to negative one I
have enough to draw this now okay are
you happy with that it's pretty rough
okay now I did it again where's my line
to reflect across it goes right smack
bang through the middle so you do your
reflection and then what do you get back
it's all the same thing okay so it's
really great when you pick an exemplar
and if it's two flags for you at the
same time there's no problem with it the
way the function being is very Universal
okay I can think of two other functions
you know simple vanilla ones that would
I could list over here
so they're really easy one is wike who's
next
can someone give me another one come on
we just did this one y equals whatever X
right it's gonna do the same thing
except such news over this way a little
bit right you're asymptotes are on the
coordinate axes okay so there's an
infinite number of functions which have
an inverse function of the function
being identical to each other okay
because there's no reason why if you
have the right symmetry just reflect
across so okay so that's how you
actually find it that's how you know the
domain and range